-The movie "Wonder Woman"
had a huge opening
at the box office this weekend.
It became the first female-led
superhero blockbuster ever.
But people
have differing opinions
about the praise
the film has received.
To make sure you get to see
the issues from both sides,
we've invited two of our writers
with contrasting points of view.
We'll examine their opinions
in a segment we call
"Point, Counterpoint."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ally and Amber, thank you for
being here to discuss this film.
First question --
"Wonder Woman" grossed over
$100 million this weekend.
Is this a definitive triumph
for women in film, Ally?
-It absolutely is.
But let's not pat ourselves
on the backs
just because Hollywood made
one blockbuster movie
with a female protagonist.
Women only account for 32% of
all speaking roles in movies.
A real triumph would be
to be bringing that ratio
to half and half.
-Half and half. Amber?
-Half and half is delicious.
Have you ever had it?
It's like if milk and ice cream
had a very yummy baby.
You can put half and half
in your coffee
or you can just
put sprinkles in it
and drink it straight
and have a party in your mouth.
-Wait. What?
-Moving on.
"Wonder Woman" is the first
successful superhero movie
directed by a woman.
Do you think
this will encourage studios
to put more women
behind the camera? Ally?
-I certainly hope so.
Right now only 7% of Hollywood
directors are women.
But I will say the true
glass ceiling will be broken
when studios give
female directors big budgets,
even after they have
a box-office flop,
just like they do
with male directors.
There's still a lot of work
to be done to achieve equality
in our nation's film canon.
-Strong words. Amber?
-I think cannons are great.
Especially when they're filled
with confetti!
One time, I jumped out
from behind my grandma's couch
and shot off a confetti cannon,
and the whole room filled with
tiny sparkles and she fainted.
[ Laughter ]
And when she came to,
she whispered, "That was fun."
-[ Laughs ] Your grandma
sounds like a great lady.
-She is. Hey, Nana!
-Seth, she's talking
about confetti
when the topic
is "Wonder Woman."
-These are things I wonder
as a woman!
You know what else I wonder?
Could I do
a Daryl Hall impression?
♪ You're a rich girl,
and you're going too far ♪
♪ But you know
it don't matter anyway ♪
I can!
-You can.
I thought he was right here.
That was amazing.
Next up.
Also breaking records this year,
the movie "Get Out",
which had a black lead
and a black director.
Could this lead to more films
for underserved audiences? Ally?
-Seth, every time a demographic
that isn't white male and 18-34
comes out to support something,
corporate America is shocked.
Why? We have jobs, we make
money, and we spend that money.
The fact that minorities
are a powerful economic force
shouldn't be a surprise.
-Well said. Amber?
-You know what's a surprise?
This.
[ Bang ]
-Aah! Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
Amber!
[ Applause ]
-Now...
[ Laughter ]
[ Both laughing ]
-Just real quick.
Let's step out of the scene
for a minute and talk --
talk about how long
we rehearsed this today.
-[ Laughing ]
I shot it backwards onto myself!
[ Laughter ]
-You two were backstage saying,
"Oh, it's so easy.
It's just a button."
[ Laughter ]
-I just accidentally shot it
right every other time.
[ Laughter ]
Oh!
-All right.
-The point is, Amber shooting
herself with a confetti cannon
is off topic.
It has nothing to do with
what we are talking about.
-Ally, this isn't
"Point, Point."
It's "Point, Counterpoint."
Okay, Ally?!
You get a point,
and then Amber gets a point!
That's how it works, Ally!
-Fine. Did we get it all?
-Yes. You look beautiful.
-Thanks, Amber.
-And finally.
"Wonder" -- [ Laughs ]
"Wonder Woman" has been
a big hit with critics.
But why do you think
it's resonating with audiences?
-You know what, Seth?
I have an answer for that,
but I won't waste my time
because I'm sure Amber
has something ridiculous
to say or do, don't you?
-Actually, I don't.
I saw "Wonder Woman"
this weekend,
and when I saw it, I cried.
It resonated with me
because I was so moved
by seeing a strong powerful
woman represented on screen.
[ Laughter ]
It's impossible
to put into words...
[ Laughter ]
...what that movie
meant to women
or how much that movie can
change the lives of young girls.
-Wow. Amber, that --
[ Laughter ]
That was beautiful.
Beautifully delivered.
[ Laughter ]
-That was --
That was truly beautiful.
[ Laughter ]
That was so much more beautiful
than anything Ally
has said or done.
-Okay. Okay.
-I also think what's
equally important is...
[ Bang ]
-Yay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Amber, stop doing that.
That's rude.
-You're right.
Where are my manners?
-Oh! Thank you.
[ Bang ]
-All right.
-Yay!
-That was fun.
-This has been
"Point, Counterpoint."
We'll be right back
with Courtney Love.
[ Laughter ]